Transcription: Sophie Goupil
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
La scène s’ouvre
à celles et ceux
qui rêvent d’un monde meilleur,
aux passionnés, aux curieux.
Aux oreilles qui regardent vers ailleurs,
aux idéaux, aux missions,
à ceux qui même sous le fracas dansent
et rythment le quotidien des projets
et des idées, qui en suggèrent la cadence.
Les idées
inspirent les mots
que l’on couche sur le papier,
qui inspire les actes
qui s’élèvent dans nos vies.
Qui inspire les expériences
qu’on transmet à autrui
qui s’en inspire
pour créer ses propres idées.
C’est un cycle voyez-vous,
un cercle vertueux.
C’est ainsi qu’on essaye
toujours de faire mieux
entre stress face à l’enjeu
et exceller dans vos yeux.
Alors certes ce n’est pas un jeu
mais quand on sait qu’cet art
vaut mieux qu’un succès sans âme et creux,
on s’excuse pas d’être harmonieux.
Elle est noble, la scène.
Elle témoigne de celle
qu’on vit au quotidien.
Elle reflète nos actes dans une pièce
jouée à pile ou face
dont nous sommes les comédiens.
Elle est un monde, la scène
une énergie qui se construit
dans le bien comme dans le mal.
Elle aspire à le changer
lorsqu’il s’égare dans un trou noir
aux idées trop ternes
pour briller parmi les étoiles
Pardon...
j’voulais pas être négatif.
On est là pour changer le monde,
pas pour le rendre dépressif.
J’ai 180 secondes pour me plier
à l’exercice entouré d’idées trop fécondes
pour que les miennes soient imprécises.
Seulement c’est quoi ?
changer le monde ?
J’veux bien...mais j’sais même pas
changer une roue de vélo.
Alors, c’est quoi ?
Changer le monde ?
J’en arrive même à me demander si c’est
pas plus simple d’en racheter un nouveau.
Alors dis moi, je suis encore crédible
pour changer le monde ?
Ou dois-je veiller
à ce que le monde ne me change pas ?
Mais je ne me range pas
du côté des résignés.
Ce soir j’ai entendu trop d’anges parler
de discours résonner
pour que mes démons penchent
parmi les idées courtes erronées
les héros naissent de leurs actes
Les vraies promesses sont des pactes
envers nous mêmes, nos rêves, nos peines
Quant au reste, on s’en écarte,
cartésien, idéaliste.
Il n’y a de bon tireur que celui
qui sait choisir la bonne cible.
Regardez bien chaque nom sur la liste
et rappelez-vous, que tout cela
ne serait pas possible
sans les adhérents, les adhérentes
les bénévoles, les regards vivants,
les âmes aidantes, la belle école
du don de soi qui prend du sens
quand dans l’assaut tout l’monde a ça
comme par essence dans la peau
les salariés, premiers à l’heure,
savent allier pro et valeurs
travailler pour prôner les leurs,
savoir faire sans paroles en l’air.
Les mécènes, messieurs, mesdames,
merci à ceux qui font don
sans qui TED ne serait pas aussi
somptueux, aussi grand.
Le public,
tant de pupilles, de tympans
dans lesquels nos paroles résonnent,
quelle portée auraient-elles
si on parlait devant personne,
alors dites-moi,
y a t il quelqu’un ici qui n’ait pas
vécu chaque Talk comme un monde à part ?
Un voyage pour les idées,
un nouveau regard.
Une belle édition touche à sa fin.
Bienvenue au point de départ
des nouvelles visions, des lendemains
qui ne croient pas au hasard,
mais à la transmission, à l’humain
à la puissance du partage, aux valeurs
qui guident la mission de Bretagne,
Ils, elles étaient 11 sur scène,
200 en backstage.
Vous êtes 2000 présents, si nombreux
derrière les écrans.
Celles et ceux qui manquent à l’appel,
à qui nous en parlerons
comme autant de battements d’ailes
qui font de l’effet papillon
notre plus belle raison de croire
que c’est ensemble qu’on fonde
bien plus que des espoirs... des idées
qui changent le monde.
[Applaudissements]